to sustain space-safe operations.
Unlike highways on earth,
there are actually no space traffic rules.
None whatsoever, OK?
Wow.
What could possibly go wrong with that?
(Laughter)
Now, what would be really nice
is if we had something like a space traffic map,
like a Waze for space that I could look up
and see what the current traffic conditions are in space,
maybe even predict these.
The problem with that, however,
is that ask five different people,
"What's going on in orbit?
Where are things going?"
and you're probably going to get 10 different answers.
Why is that?
It's because information about things on orbit is not commonly shared either.
So what if we had a globally accessible,
open and transparent space traffic information system
that can inform the public of where everything is located
to try to keep space safe and sustainable?
And what if the system could be used
to form evidence-based norms of behavior --
these space traffic rules?
So I developed ASTRIAGraph,
the world's first crowdsourced, space traffic monitoring system
at the University of Texas at Austin.
ASTRIAGraph combines multiple sources of information from around the globe --
government, industry and academia --
and represents this in a common framework that anybody can access today.
Here, you can see 26,000 objects orbiting the earth,
multiple opinions,
and it gets updated in near real time.
But back to my problem of space traffic map:
What if you only had information from the US government?
Well, in that case, that's what your space traffic map would look like.
But what do the Russians think?
That looks significantly different.
Who's right? Who's wrong?
What should I believe?
What could I trust?
This is part of the issue.
In the absence of this framework to monitor space-actor behavior,
to monitor activity in space --
where these objects are located --
to reconcile these inconsistencies
and make this knowledge commonplace,
we actually risk losing the ability
to use space for humanity's benefit.
Thank you very much.
(Applause and cheers)